trigonometric equations is what we're
looking at immediately before
what you've just done okay so let's just
remember we looked at
like three basic kinds or maybe three
and a half basic kinds
of equations with trig functions in them
that we can solve okay
so we started with the most basic kind
the most basic okay so remembering that
for all of these there's a domain
just for the sake of illustration i'm
not going to write the domain i'm just
going to assume not to 360.
basic things are ones like this
okay you've just got one trig function
equal to a value and you're expected to
find the solutions
between not and 360 you tend to get two
there are some other examples where you
might get zero uh or one or
more but that's basically it so that's
what it looks like
we shook it up a little bit by adjusting
now i'll just give you a bit of a um
i'll give you a fancy working
adjusting this term which is called the
argument
right it's what's being put into the the
actual trig function
so adjusting the argument there were two
main ways
that we looked at we looked at throwing
a coefficient in there
so something like this which had what
effect
what effect would that have
it's it's going to be it's going to be
twice
as frequent as the regular old sinex
curve so you're going to get twice as
many solutions you get four solutions to
this one to 360
rather than two that was one way we
looked at it
or instead of changing the frequency
we could change what we call the phase
right so we could move it over
for instance i think i gave you this
we could move it over left or right some
number of degrees
okay and our solutions would move
accordingly the last kind that we looked
at
is kind of like this but it's when you
introduce
you know you square something right so
for instance if i said
sine squared x equals
a half and this changed things in a
couple of different ways
number one it simply changed the value
right so sine x is not going to be a
half
sine x in fact should be one on root two
right when you take the square root of
both sides
but it's not only one and root two it's
also
negative one and root two so you get
plus or minus
so we noticed that even though this was
like more complicated it's actually kind
of easier
because it means that if you're thinking
of this
if you're picturing this it means you
have solutions
in all quadrants right so you'd have in
this case 45
135 225 315 you get four solutions
okay or alternatively if you think about
the graph you're going to slice in
at one over two and minus one over two
so more solutions
therefore if this is where we've been
it's a very
logical next step when we think about
okay what does it mean to make these
harder right is to take this right by
the way let me give you some language
for this okay
if i showed you an equation like this
okay this is a quadratic we're familiar
with calling it that okay but this
is more specifically it's a quadratic in
x right let me even write that down it's
a quadratic
in x x is the variable right so if i
change this up and i said this
okay this is still a quadratic but it's
a quadratic
in y okay so therefore it doesn't take
that much imagination to think well i
can have quadratics
in all kinds of other things i just take
you know these bits and i just replace
them with something else
okay so i'm going to give you a series
of examples i've got six and this is why
i rubbed off the homework i'm going to
write them all here
some of them are simpler than others
we're going to add more layers of
complexity for all of these
you may if it helps you i don't think
it's necessary but if it helps you
you may approach these by using a
substitution
okay so for instance you might say for
number one
uh the traditional variable for
substituting for these kinds of things
is you
because x and y are taken in z generally
means
something quite different and don't ask
me about v and w
u is the traditional one so i could say
let u
equal cos theta okay now if that's what
i'm
defining then i could rewrite that
equation like so
okay now just before we move off this
okay
and come back to the trig functions just
like if you receive this
in algebra right you could divide both
sides by
u but you shouldn't why not
okay right if i had divided both sides
by u i wouldn't get anything wrong
assuming
u is not zero i would get u equals one
which
is a solution okay but as has been
pointed out it's not the
only solution where transit for we've
transformed the quadratic
into a linear equation so you'd expect
oh i
was having two solutions but now i've
just got one okay so that's why they
disappear
instead what would be a better way to
approach this question okay
and my suggestion was let's take out a
factor
of u okay so i've done it
from here you could go ahead and you
know what to do in terms of the algebra
right
i'm just going to suggest particularly
for the cases easiest number one or even
number two
or well actually for all of these you
don't necessarily need to go to the
lengths of defining the whole thing
you can just work with it as it is and
do the same kind of steps
so for instance instead of this i'm just
going to start the first line
i'm going to go cos squared equals cos
take it over to one side and then
factorize it
as you normally would and now you can
solve it okay
so there are two ways to solve this one
for this factor and one for this factor
right so the way i would set this out
is i would lay it out like that i'd say
cos theta equals
zero will give me one of the solutions
and cos theta equals
one will give me the other set of
solutions right so where does cos theta
equal zero
what values i'm going to do 90 90 and
270.
that's what i meant to say okay and then
for cos theta equals one again
two solutions in the domain zero three
all the way down all the way up and 360.
180 so yes if we are not giving
given the range in which visa can lie
doesn't that mean it's going to be your
thesis
yes and you will be given you will be
given a domain i will talk about what
happens when you don't get given a
domain which is
a later part of this topic but just
because i'm kind of sick of writing it
and i want to save space and whiteboard
marketing
i'm just saying autopsy for all this and
that will be the default
okay so the next most common is minus
180 to 180 when they're just trying to
throw a curveball at you but
95 of the time okay okay now
strictly speaking i really should tie
this all up in a bow
and say look here's two parts of it and
i should say therefore
and then i should list out all four okay
in this case because they're so close to
each other i could probably get away
and you could probably get away with
just writing that but sometimes
like one side will be dramatically
easier to solve than the other side and
there'll be like a mess here and by the
time you've gotten to the end of six or
seven lines
this answer and this answer are far far
apart okay so it's worth taking the 10
seconds to write them 0
90 270 360
all in a row okay and that's it
that's all there is to it